(crowd cheering)
- [Sam] What's up
- Well it's nice to see
you in person this time.
- [Sam] Yes!
- Yeah. That's hilarious.
- Oh, thank you. I hope so.
- Oh my gosh, it's so funny.
So ha- have y'all ever met before, Jen?
- No, it's our first time.
- [Kelly] Okay, right on.
- It's nice to meet you.
- That was hilarious.
- Thank you so much.
- I'm like, just the one
clip and I'm in. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- But last time, I don't think
I got a chance to ask you
how, like, how did you get
into like standup, in comedy?
- Man, I started standup, I was 29.
- [Kelly] Ah.
- Just looking for direction, really.
Just kind of feeling like I had a life
with no purpose and I
always wanted to do it.
So I was like, yo, just give it a shot.
- Yeah.
- And I went up
and I did this open mic and I got booed
(Crowd Chuckles)
- [Jen] Oh, (beep).
- Immediately
- [Kelly] Wow.
- But the setup was bad.
The setup was bad.
- Yeah.
- It was like at a bar
and they were watching football
and then they like turned
off the football and they were
like, it's comedy time y'all.
And
- [Kelly] Oh
- that already sets you
up for like failure.
- That was, that was Satan's work.
- Yeah, right.
- That was the devil's work.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It wasn't the best position to be in.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Pressure!
- Drunk football fans.
- Yeah.
- Wow that was...
- But you kept going.
- Yeah, it was like, as
soon as I got on the mic too
I was like, you ever, and
someone was like, boo!
And I was like Aww (Jen and Crowd Laughs)
- [Sam] Cool.
- Do you lean into a heckler?
- Um That time?
No. I was like, you know
what, I'm gonna just leave
and let you guys do what you want to do.
- Oh my God. Deuces.
- But I wasn't discouraged,
which is the most important thing.
- That's what I'm saying.
- Yes
- You kept going. (Clapping)
That's incredible.
- For sure.
- And that's an incredible
story to tell people
because everybody thinks it's
so easy when they see us here
and it's like, there are a lot
of doors that are shut
and mean uh men usually
involved (Sam chuckles)
but there is a lot of things
that happen that deter you.
- Yes.
- You know? So that's really
cool that you kept going.
What a great story that is.
- Yeah. Man, you got to
or you won't get to where
you're trying to go, you know?
- Amen. I get it. I get it.
- Yes, thick skin
- What's your toughest moment
on stage? You ever been
- Ooh
- like booed or any
kind of weird situation?
- Yeah. Well, my very first time on stage
was my first recital
performance. I fell like, I -
we were bumblebees and I
fell and knocked all the
other bumblebees down Kelly.
like, like dominoes.
They all just went down because of me.
And so my very, the fact that
I kept with it and was like
- Right
you know
I'm gonna keep doing this even
though I- I- failed miserably
- Did they all turn on you?
Like behind, backstage?
- I think we were too young.
But, you know, few years later
it probably would've been opposite
- You were the goal
- You were the bee that ruined it all
- The Bee!
- And they're holding onto it.
- But you know, you do the
thing afterwards where you
uh uh uh yeah. That that was meant to be.
That was meant to be.
And they were like, oh, Jen, you fell.
- I have fallen on stage, not as a kid.
- For real?
- Oh. Like full on over.
I fell back, I think it was
over Corey's board, like his
guitar, whatever you call that.
I don't play guitar.
And I um pedal board.
Thank you.
And I fell back on it and then
literally the mic somehow hit
and it was like, it made
the sound from movies like,
(Screeching Noise)
like that hole, in an amphitheater filled
with like 12,000 people
(laughing) and, and it and
and I just got back up and
like Mary Katherine Gallagher-ed it
and was like, yeah, superstar.
And I just kept going.
- That is my biggest fear.
- To fall?
- Oh, don't let it be
because you know what?
Just get back up and you just
lean into the fact that like
- But when you're doing
comedy, you're falling alone.
Like at least you have, (laughs) you just-
- Trust me. Trust me. I
felt alone.(Crowd Laughs)
I didn't feel like I had a
team of people fall with me.
- Yeah.
- On my whole band knows
me too.(Jen and Sam Laugh)
So they're all laughing like,
everybody's like, oh damn
she went down.
You think she's getting up?
Like it was like it wasn't good.
It was hilarious, but I
got back up, whatever.
So now you're in a
movie with an SNL Great.
This is incredible.
- Yeah.
- With Eddie Murphy. So
like, what is this movie
about? (Crowd Claps) And how
excited and stoked are you?
- Man, I'm super, super, super excited
for this movie to come out.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- I can't wait for
people to see it and just
feel what we were trying to give them.
- Yeah
- And I mean it's about
interracial relationship
and also an interfaith relationship.
Uh Lauren London and Jonah
Hill are dating. He's Jewish,
she's Muslim and black. And
it's just about all the ups
and downs of that.
And how when two people are
just trying to be in love
there's all these outside
forces that kind of try to
tear them apart.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Based on their own preconceived
ideas of what that love is
- Based on what society
has told us we should.
- [Sam] Yes.
- Yeah.
- [Sam] Exactly.
- That's interesting.
I love that you're taking
such a serious heavy topic
but with humor
- [Sam] I think that's
the best way to do it.
- That's the best way. Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah
And then it's like thought-provoking.
That's my favorite- I
always say this to Joe
That it's my favorite thing
to watch something
that's thought-provoking.
Then afterwards you and your
friends are like discussing.
- Right. You gotta put a
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Little bit of like
medicine in the laughter.
I think that's how it gets through.
- [Kelly] Nice.
- Medicine in the laughter?
- [Sam] Yeah.
- [Jen] Ooh.
- Put that on a bumper sticker. Yeah.
- You already got it.
- [Kelly] Yeah. All right. All right.